por la pandemia nuestras crónicas son en
casa y la de hoy invita a deconstruir
los a través del arte este no está
exento de discriminaciones hacia el
colectivo lgtb
plus pero a la vez intenta ir más allá
de lo normativo un buen ejemplo es la
obra teatral the voice and band man
crawley la escribió en el 68 pensando
que las tramas sobre homosexuales eran
escasas entonces resultó transgresor que
un cumpleaños de amigos gays fuera lo
protagónico pero la visita da como
adaptación de ryan murphy sigue
impactando ya que revela como el entorno
afecta a la identidad y cómo se cambia
el comportamiento si como aquí hay un
personaje que rechaza la diversidad y es
homófobo
lo que se intenta muchas veces es que
una persona que pertenezca al colectivo
el gtd acaba de comportándose como lo
haría un heterosexual que se case que
tenga hijos que se compre una casa que
entra dentro de lo que de lo que
esperamos como sistema
quien habla es el artista al amor
evangelista y a modo de crowley sus
ilustraciones a la cuenta mover fuera al
nombre las realidades que nos rodean en
2020 que hacías ahí dentro pues creo que
me metieron cuando tenía seis años qué
manía componer el matrimonio y la
adopción como muestra del fin de la
lgtb-fobia si no me dejas participar por
no cumplir con los estándares de una
mujer estás ejerciendo la misma opresión
que has venido a denunciar sea en carne
propia o no no siempre entendemos que es
el género no binario o que es traspasar
la orientación e identidad sexual
aceptadas sin embargo el artista rompe
esas dudas nos receta aún de construye
till y nos dice las etiquetas nos sirven
para nombrar pero quienes nos definimos
somos nosotros el género es algo
individual que creamos junto a la
identidad esa presión por ejemplo se
debe mucho a la comunidad trans porque
cuanto más parece es una mujer más te
acepta a la sociedad y cuanto menos
pareces es más eres el fritz y de la
sociedad que queda apartado y entonces
yo lo que intento transmitir es al final
defínete como tú eres sé como tú eres y
osea es muy difícil muchas veces el
ignorar yo eso pero tener en cuenta de
que es válido el hecho de que tú eres
así y ya está y eso no implica que
tengas que vestir de una forma o por una
forma hablar de una forma o moverte de
una forma lo interesante de modelo fue
es que vía el dibujo de ejemplos de
personalidades este octubre refleja el
ser trans como una forma de ser que ni
se debaten y se niega y aborda la
lgtb-fobia incluyendo a las personas etc
en la lucha del orgullo pero su plus es
el humor es relatar esa estereotipada
pluma que va con la personalidad o que
los tratamientos no funcionan igual para
todos y aún más es capaz de visibilizar
que en esas siglas hay desigualdades
marcados muchas veces por la clase
social
es lo que la teoría queer al final habla
de eso de que todas las opresiones y
discriminaciones entrelazan y es muy
complicado separarlas todas de golpe así
alguien pobre va a estar mucho más
invisibilizado que alguien rico una
persona realizada va a estar mucho más
invisibilizada que una persona blanca
el problema es olvidarse de que de que
eso son varias letras que están juntas
de decirlo como una palabra pienso si al
final se aglutina eso dice ser gente
vehículo plus y ya está y en realidad
sólo estamos viendo
a dos games captchas y ya está
en otros temas la pandemia está dando a
la cultura una de cal y otra de arena
por un lado está generando una gran
crisis en el palacio de versalles faltó
desde marzo del 80% de visitantes ya
nueva york' la ha despojado de sus artes
escénicas destruyendo entre abril y
julio 153 mil de 280 mil empleos del
sector por primera vez en 140 años la
ópera metropolitana no tendrá temporada
hasta septiembre como tampoco la tendrán
hasta junio la filarmónica y las salas
de broadway devastadas por estas tierras
históricos
[Música]
y la parte de arena es que a la par hay
muestras colosales como una de la
colección torlonia en rojo desde el
siglo 15 al 19 la aristocrática familia
fue reuniendo el mayor conjunto de obras
grecorromanas del mundo pero ahora este
deleite privado ha pasado al ojo público
en los museos capitolinos con miras de
iniciar una gira y luego crear un museo
permanente hoy se exhiben 92 de 620
piezas del catálogo si bien entre ellas
hay sarcófagos bustos y estatuas que van
desde criaturas míticas hasta
emperadores y generales y que según sus
restauradores son como acariciar la
belleza durante cuatro años sus manos
han sentido en el mármol intervenciones
de siglos pasados como la de el cabrón
en reposo la cabra en reposo la época da
por el artista barroco bernini
y restauró con los excelentes co en el
siglo 18 el objetivo de la restauración
era imitar las imperfecciones nosotras
por el contrario cuidamos el lado
artístico pero tratamos de no esconder
nuestras intervenciones todo debe ser
reconocible incluida la mano del
restaurador usada no como humano de
artistas sino como instrumento
científico en la nota final la pone el
creador web que lo definimos así porque
en su segundo trabajo ese 16 en honor al
azufre el francés johann lengua confirma
que es cantautor y músico pero también
visionario de la imagen hace 7 años en
su disco debut de golden age nos cristo
rambo y rand desde las heridas de la
infancia hoy regresa con la ética de
goliat para cuestionar las grandes
fuerzas del mundo y contraponer en forma
de thriller política y emoción tinieblas
con claridad intimidad con universal
cuídense y muchas gracias
sí no
[Música]
t
trae